bismillah come to the last Salaam
alaikum peace be unto you greetings of
peace for all the viewers who are tuning
in from all over the globe and there are
many of you who are about to attend
college and it cost big money and how do
you get into college without getting
into the river without getting into the
Ussery without getting into the
interest-based loans
we're going to give you some tips and
trips how to reduce the debt and how to
avoid the interest all of this and more
on this week's important episode here on
the D show when we come back don't go
anywhere
this is the great to meet you - how are
you doing I'm doing great very happy to
be here today so your organization
continuous charity is that what it's
called yes a continuous chain a
continuous charity helping people
students primarily people who are trying
to go to a higher level education not to
fall into the interest not to fall into
the user is that right exactly that's
what our mission is before we get into
you know some of these tips and tricks
let's define because some people like
what's the big deal we know that in
Islam the way of life that was continued
to be spread through all the messages of
God there was a code of conduct there
was more allergic relations ethical
everything business nothing was left out
and interest was one of those things
that not only was it prohibited
throughout christianity judaism in
earlier times you know many countries
had outlawed it islam to this day
continues to prohibit interest usury in
common terms the layman loan shark and
we call it you know what i mean exist it
can you tell us you know a little bit so
people can kind of get in tune with when
we talk about interest why is this
something that salaam is so firmly
against well that's a great question
interest is something that ensures that
the majority of the population will
remain poor while a small portion that
population will remain wealthy imagine
this scenario and man if you're a guy in
you're poor and you want to buy a car
versus another man who's wealthier and
he wants to buy that same car the
wealthier person can go and just buy the
car pay the $10,000 for it and now he
owns the car the one who is poor though
he'll have to go and take out a loan
maybe that has interest on it and he'll
end up paying more for that exact same
car
the man who's wealthy and thus making
him go further into debt
another challenge of interest and the
reason it was forbidden by every group
is that you're making money off of money
itself rather than selling a service or
selling a product or doing some type of
work because you're rich because you're
wealthy because you have a lot of money
stashed away somewhere you're able to
then loan that out with guaranteed
interest on it so that the rest of the
society is paying you more to use your
money and then that makes the richer
rich and that the poorer poor this is
one the reason not only Islam but every
single major religion out there and even
countries and nations and empires forbid
the use of interest or ribah
because what it would do is they would
polarize wealth within that society even
ensure that those who are wealthy are
wealthy just because they're wealthy and
those who are poor who need the money
true by legitimate things that they will
get into further debt and Islam the
problem of Salalah Allah may peace and
blessings of the Almighty be upon him he
was staunch in forbidding the use of
interest and RIBA and it is something
that even during the final sermon that
proud Muhammad peace be upon him gave to
humanity where he said that there's no
better person amongst you that a black
man is no better than a white man white
man no better than black man and one of
the main things he emphasized is to stay
away from interest to stay away from
using ribah because it will economically
enslave you today we're living in a
country in a world where not only
individual entire nations are in debt
and enslaved to other people in fact
what our organization does primarily is
with student loans and in the United
States student loans is actually higher
now than the home loans that people have
it is the single largest debt in the
United States and why is it like this
it's because these lenders they know
that people need an education to go to
school they need to get a good degree
they need to be able to have in higher
education and some encourages getting an
education but what they do is they give
these loans with high interest knowing
that this population gonna take those
interest bearing alone and yet it'll
take a months years decades to pan back
in fact I was at a convention recently
with Akina and I met a man who is 60
years old and he's a well-to-do person
he's very well-off and he still hasn't
paid off his college loans and I was
children and now even his grandchildren
are eventually gonna go into school so
it shows you the evil that interest has
on the society in slave's an individual
it economically binds them that they
have to work just to pay off a debt that
they took many years ago absolutely we
see that Islam you know one of the major
misconceptions is that is a new religion
brought by Mohammed but we know the
Islam is the same way of life that was
lived through all the messengers Jesus
Moses Abraham they all call people to
worship the Creator not the creation we
always like to simplify things here on
the Deen show adultery is forbidden
gambling you know alcohol the use of
drugs all of these things that are
detriment to society and one of them
were talking about today is interest
it's interesting that you know when you
look at what's left today of the Bible
for instance you see that in there it is
the call to worship the Creator not the
creation you see you know Islam is
actually in the Bible remnants of it are
still there even though it's been
changed but you see for instance if I
get it Leviticus it says do not take
interest of any kind but fear God also
an exodus it clearly says if you lend
money lend it without interest we see
Jesus who we love no Muslim is a Muslim
unless he believes and loves Jesus one
of the mightiest messages God ever sent
he actually had a whip and he whipped
the money changers who are pedaling in
the in the house of worship this is
amazing so this is something that we are
still continuing this tradition till
today because it's the pure tradition so
another example can you take off from
here isn't an equivalent tell so I said
loan-sharking you know Tony Knuckles
comes and gives you a hundred dollars
you know what I mean and then he says
okay go ahead here's a hundred but after
you know one one year you got to pay him
to three thousand back exactly and
actually this is a really good example
that you came up with is that one of the
reasons that every single religion
forbid the use of interest is because it
is a form of oppression that exists
within that society and even in Islam
the forbidding of interest is a example
of loan sharking because what loan
sharking is it that I'll give you the
money you need
now in order to get even legitimate
things but you'll have to pay more back
for it and what that does is it then
forces that individual that everyday
they don't pay it back they get further
and further and further into debt and of
course loan sharks just like modern-day
lenders they target those people who are
easy to target which are students and
even we have a situation where students
it's almost impossible to go to college
and it's almost impossible to get higher
education unless you take out an
interest-bearing loan and what that
means is that entire generation that
people are now enslaved to this enslave
so we're gonna teach you how not to
educate you so you don't get shackled by
this and you can slave your whole life
by being in debt and then you're also
incurring the anger the one who created
you who wants the best for you and he
knows best so we're gonna be educating
you some more here on addy show don't go
anywhere
so cool Allah who say he allows one God
is one the maker America exactly Allah
was somewhat lost self-sufficient
he doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day okay I
really had a problem with that even
before I knew anything about Islam God
resting sounds like a weak guy yeah
Lamia lit well I'm you let he begets not
he doesn't have any children notice he
had a child or born of anything or
anyone well then yeah cool I hope you
like I had and there's nothing co-equal
or comparable to him at all nobody
nothing Jesus nobody nobody is
comparable to the Creator nothing yeah
and that right there was in his essence
what I believe naturally
you
back here on the D show very important
topic very important because today you
end up getting this interest and like
you mentioned an individual now will go
to school four years six years eight
years however many years and then his
whole life her whole life they'll be
enslaved on paying off because you get a
fifty thousand hundred thousand dollar
loan by the time you end up paying it
off you've got almost in current 803
pulse right so we want to talk about
more about how not to get enslaved and
the creator is telling us now the
severity of this in the Koran so we will
talk more about this what the creator's
saying I mentioned what we have left in
the Bible of this what is the crater
saying about interests in the Koran
so actually what allah subhanho wa taala
allah god almighty he says in the quran
is that it is very harsh dependent for
those who give interest right the
contract for interest or take interest
in fact allah subhanaw taala god
almighty he says he never in the Quran
declares war upon anybody except for
those people who engage in interests in
fact it's described that if you engage
in interest that when you're resurrected
on the day of judgment that you'll be
given weapons and you'll be told to go
and go to war with allah subhanaw taala
and his messenger why because interest
is a form of economic warfare that
exists within this world as well in fact
another very strong hadeep is that
interest it divides seventy categories
the least evil of all these seventy
categories would be equivalent to you
committing zina or doing a sexual act
with your mother in front of the Kaaba
right so the way interested ascribed in
the Quran is something very very
terrible very evil to do and of course
the reason is because in Islam giving a
loan is something positive giving
somebody a loan to borrow something
legitimate is something a beautiful
blessing in fact it's a form of sadaqa
and what people do is that they use what
should be good what should be as a mean
of game blessing for themselves and they
add their percentage to it to make sure
that that person will pay them more just
because they gave him money so loaning
people money is something
very legitimate something encouraged but
lonely people with interest is something
that is of course forbidden son that we
should all stay away from now we know
that when Islam when it was the
superpower of the world for at one point
from what is it around 800 to 1600 s we
see that there were no interest based
loans and people were prospering you
know those abundance of wealth to give
out because some people people will say
well then how can the system work
what would you say well actually you'll
find that when a system an economic
system does not load interest that
economy Rises look at America after the
economic recession happened what did the
federal government do they lowered
interest rates right and the big concern
is they're gonna increase those interest
rates again after the recession happened
you could actually go and buy a car with
0% interest why what does that do
because now people are not buying your
product you see when you have interest a
person isn't buying anything they're not
going to your shop they're not going you
have a martial art studio downstairs
they're not going to these places there
are money that they make goes into
paying the interest on their loan that
weekends in the economy and it actually
fractures and destroys an economy so
this is why the Islamic state was able
to right and something unique Eddie that
many people don't know is that the
Ottoman Empire one of the last thing
that happened before they eventually
collapsed and were taken over is that
they for the first time took out loans
that had interest on them in order to
pay to westernize their empire so
actually one the last acts that the
armin party is they got into debt for
overall hundreds of years they're never
in debt and then they go into debt and
then shortly afterward they collapse
there is a direct correlation because
when your empire or when your country is
in debt and it's an interest-bearing
debt it means that there's a high chance
you'll never be able to get out of it
and that's what creates chaos yeah we
can when we study we see from history
when they were biting firmly by the
Quran in the son of the verbatim speech
of the creator and the example of the
last final master that were prospering
exactly now you gave a great example now
they went against this and you see they
collapsed and tell us now I compared it
one more point you know the the loan
shark and and now these bankers they got
the loan sharks officers
but took this business over right and
this is one of the saddest realities
that we see is that the difference
between a loan shark and a banker is the
amount of interest they charged so a
loan shark might charge 300 percent
interest while a banker will charge
maybe seven eight or ten percent
interest but the challenge is that is
still interest you're still having to
take out a loan in order to go to
college you still have to take out a
loan in order to get a house you have to
take out an interest-bearing loan to do
all these very legitimate things and the
reality is that there has to be a better
way when I can buy a house and if
there's a day that I can buy a house I
can go to school without have with maybe
I'll take a loan but without interest
that means I know exactly how much I
took I know that every dollar I give
goes into decreasing that loan rather
than every dollar I give goes maybe into
even just paying off the interest there
are some people today who whenever they
pay off their loan they're not paying a
single dollar off of their actual no
they're only paying the interest on that
loan which means again they'll never get
out and this is Sunday as Muslims and as
people of all faiths or no faiths we
should stand against this type of
economic system we should be able to
stand up and say we'd want another
option that we want to be able to take
out these loans and or but not pay
interest on them and when you have zero
percent interest the economy Rises when
you have zero percent interest people go
out and they buy think they'll buy
services you have zero interest you will
actually grow many people because it
seems like for a lot of people this is
complicated but when we simplify people
like yes would you rather be paying a
mortgage payment or a loan that's let's
say 2,000 a month now you're giving back
but actually 1706 70% is going towards
just the interest if that you know what
I mean
so in Islam it's like how do you do it
if you lend lend them lend the money
there's no interest you don't go ahead
and exploit the people and then we see
now during this financial crisis where
people were losing their homes even if
they had paid off let's say 60% they
still lost a home they didn't care it
was taken away can you expound on this
right so part of the way that home loans
worked inside the United States
is that the bank buys the home or
actually they give you a loan and then
you buy the home the challenges that
until you
parent higher mortgage you don't really
have access to the house so when people
when the recession hit and people
basically lost their jobs and they
weren't able to make those monthly
payments the government threw them on
the street or the banks they threw them
on the streets now that makes no sense
a person needs a place to live the bank
will get its money back but maybe for a
few months they can't they can't pay
their mortgage so this type of thinking
they're thinking of forgetting that
these are human beings and I just
looking at the numbers this person is a
number to me how much turn loan em and
how much profit can I make off of him
when that's happened psychologically
within the bank of the economic
institutions collapse will happen and
failures will happen we're gonna take a
break and now you can see why Allah the
creator the one who loves you
he's severe in the tearing you from
going towards these things that's why
you will see that Islam is there to
protect not only you as an individual
but the whole society as a whole we'll
be right back with more to give you some
tips and trips how to reduce getting
into debt your debt and educate you on
how to get non-interest based loans for
school we'll be right back
take that simple step that you asked
your maker to guide you that he'll guide
you yes III advise this a lot so for
people who are searching put your head
on the floor in the in the in the state
of prostration like all the prophets did
and ask the creator of the universe to
show you the way to guide you to the
straight path and someone who sincerely
us will guide their suppose I found it
in your son that's it back here on the
Dean show and we'll start off this next
section with the brother that I know he
actually went to dental school
his brother Rami it's a good friend of
mine and what he did was masha'Allah he
was determined to go to dental school so
what he did he went to individuals one
by one people with money and he got a
bunch of different loans from let's say
this doctor this friend this colleague
until he was able to acquire enough now
money loans without interest and he just
recently completed his degree in in
dentistry amazing so that's one thing
that you know from his experience we can
share what what are the things and
before we get into your program can
people do some of these you've done a
video on some tips and tricks how to
reduce your debt and then we'll get into
how what people can do to not get into
these loans right that's a fantastic
question you know on our website 8
continues charity or part of our mission
and power our vision is to create an
online educational platform where people
can go and learn on how to reduce their
debt some basic tips if you're going to
college
number one try your best not to live on
the on house camping try not to live in
the dorms as they say because the dorms
are designed order to make profit for
the actual University also what you
should do is try not to get a meal plan
the meal plan is basically they'll give
you two meals a day or three meals a day
but they're over inflated overcharged so
that's another Avenue you should try to
avoid a third thing you can try is when
you go to school try to have a part-time
job while you're in school as well even
if you work only on the weekends even if
you make a few hundred dollars a month
that's a few hundreds less than you'll
have to pay on interest another thing is
apply for scholarships
you'll be surprised many many
scholarships never get applied for so if
you're going to score if you're going to
college apply for these scholarships you
might actually get some of these
scholarships and it might really
surprise you as well and there's a list
of things that people and students can
do in order to make the burden of going
to college a little bit less another
idea depending on what you're studying
of course is if you go to college try
going to a community college for the
first two years and then go into normal
college afterwards again you have to
check whether that call will accept
those credits and also some program like
medical and whatnot they won't accept
that but for many degrees and many
programs you can do this and it does not
lessen your other degree as well so
there are just some advices that people
can do now your organization clearly
there is no interest whatsoever and
these loans that you guys give so
something unique about a continuous
charity is that we are a non-profit
we're not a bank so what we do is we
basically if we loan to my ten thousand
dollars they pay us back exactly ten
thousand dollars the way we do that is
we've started this very unique program
in our concept is that we work with
Muslims all across the United States and
we partner with their Islamic centers
the goal is that every single Islamic
Center every single budget should think
how are you gonna get our kids through
college without taking on
interest-bearing debt and
interest-bearing loan and when they
think about that we go to these
communities we help them raise local
pools of funds and then we basically
administer it so if you're going to a
budget in Chicago and they raise $50,000
then you because you live in Chicago you
have access to that money and again when
you take out a loan you're paying it
back and the idea is that that money
never goes down so every dollar we raise
with a continuous charity is one dollar
less that's going into ribah and of
course you know the older generation
they use their loans to go to college
and then they pay it back in its avail
for the next generation and the next
generation and the next generation
that's even why our name comes from our
name is a continuous chain which comes
from a hadith of the personal loss
column that says that when a man dies
all of his deeds stop except for three
the first is sadaqa jariya
a continuous charity the second is now
beneficial knowledge that helps the
society after that and the third is a
righteous child that prays for him so
our idea is that a
every loan we give out isn't is a sadaqa
jariya because we give 10,000 to this
person he paid it back immediately their
money is recycled and given to somebody
else so we're hoping to create this
conversation amongst the Muslims across
the United States and in shell across
the world that we should not be
defeatist you know we are Muslims we are
the ones who Allah Samantha says that
you're the best of Nations and when
there's injustice in the world that we
should be the ones leading the charge
against that injustice and
interest-bearing loans affects everybody
regardless of race ethnicity now I
believe that Muslims we are in a unique
ability in order to challenge this in
the United States and if we're able to
do that here and make a mouth at work
then inshallah the entire world as well
I think everybody doesn't matter if
you're if you're someone who's just
level-headed and doesn't matter how much
you hate Islam once you get to know
Islam and the justice of Islam the
fairness of Islam I think now they would
even come to you to say give us the loan
rather than you know these guys just
charges these outstanding landish
interest rates in that so this is just
the the common sense way to go right
actually let me give you one quick story
when we opened our account in at Bank of
America we actually wasn't spoke with
the bank manager there and she also does
investments as well so she said what do
you guys do and we told him that we give
out the down interest based loans so
people can go to college and then she
stopped and they said non-muslim lady
she works at the bait yeah and she
looked at me she said can you please fix
America a non-muslim lady who works at
the bank who works at the economic
institution realize that what we're
doing is so amazing so fundamental and
again it's all from our one crib because
as you mentioned God He loves us and he
creates an economic system a political
system a worshipping system in order for
the human being to have peace
tranquility and justice in their life
and a non-muslim understand that Muslims
understand that and I hope that we're
able to really benefit you your
community by giving you these non test
based loans and insha'Allah God willing
you can invite us and we can help set
this up in your community as well we're
almost out of time you also have some
scholars one has been on the show a
sheikh ibrahim sedan's and some others
who've looked at your operation how it
works and
also back this yes so Sheikh Ibrahim is
done and many others have looked at the
way our organization works and they've
acted because again we're a nonprofit if
we are for-profit corporation I don't
think we could operate but because we're
nonprofit every dollar we get we loan it
out to somebody else we take five
percent for administrative fees just to
keep our office and staff running and
that's it that's as simple as the
organization works and now again how
could people get a hold of you or get
involved in this program now if they
also want to contribute or to go ahead
and get a loan from you guys too many
ways first of all if you want to partner
with us if you think this is an
important program that you want to bring
to your community please contact me go
to WWE continuous charity dot org and
then invite us to your community and
help us set up you're the first of
investment program in your community
that way people can donate in order to
help your students go to college and you
guys get our priority for that and
secondly of course just visit our
website it continues cherry dot org and
all of our information is there chuckle
hi oh my God Almighty the credit Ward's
you thank you so much for me it's been a
pleasure thank you and there you have it
another avenue that you can pursue to go
ahead and get your degree but you can do
it in a way that's not going to that's
not going to harm you in the future in
this life and definitely in the next so
you see we replaced it with something
better you can go ahead to this
organization instead of getting involved
in RIBA and usury and interest loan
sharking you can go ahead and do it the
right way
so when we go ahead and we take
something we replace it with something
better so now you're leaving off the
alcohol we replace it with all these
hundreds of juices fruit juice dis juice
that juice go ahead and we replacing the
dating fornication with marriage the
Halal way the how allow style
worshipping sticks stones men and women
leaving all that junk off and worshiping
the one that created you
it's llamas just it's for all it's the
way of life that's merciful that's
kindness from the Creator the one who
made you that's right the one you're
gonna return back to and he's giving you
a system away and if you follow it you
got Jenna you got paradise at the end if
you go away from it Hellfire is there
none of us want to imagine that we'll
end up there but it's a place it's been
created we want to avoid it we want to
end up agenda so follow the way that's
pleasing to your Creator before you meet
your Creator
follow us on the Facebook Twitter share
the Dean show
contribute to the DS show so we continue
we continue delivering this message to
the world we'll see you next time until
then peace be unto you